You know, unfortunately it wouldn't be
a Christmas special in 2020
without the following segment.
Take a look.
(dramatic music)
[Narrator] It's time
for a Qanon News Break.
America, this Christmas
it's time to wake up
and learn the identity
of the biggest deep state
criminal of them all: Santa Claus.
(bells jingling)
Born Saint Nick in 270 AD,
Santa has survived to this day
by feasting on the plasma
of millions of children.
His bright red cheeks proof
of his insatiable lust.
How does he get away with it?
Because for years Santa
has been propped up
by the Hollywood pedo industrial complex
where he's been featured
in over 100 films,
all glorifying his maniacal
invasion of younsters' homes
to harvest their blood.
Yes, Hollywood, where Santa is sheltered
thanks to his carefully
cultivated relationship
with power broker, Brooke Shields,
and coddled by the warm embrace
of the mainstream news media.
Santa is here!
[Narrator] No wonder
he's able to move freely
among the deep state's greatest felons.
And now meet Santa's boss,
shown for the first time
in this deleted scene
from a children's classic
where Rudolph surveys his kingdom.
Bow down.
[Narrator] And Santa is
broken and brought to heal
by the evil reindeer and
his eight demon disciples.
Yes, Rudolph, who keeps
Santa on a short leash
as he in turn administers
to his deep state minions.
Melania tried to warn us
with her Santa hat trees,
but we wouldn't listen.
So now it's time for all of us
to wake up before it's too late.
Next time on Qanon News Break.
Learn how Jesus Christ,
a confirmed bachelor and known Jew,
who is beloved by Hollywood
and confessed to spending 40 days
at a desert retreat with the devil,
might just be the biggest deep state
double agent of them all.
This has been a Qanon News Break.
Man, that makes you
think, doesn't it, Andy?
Yeah, think that my great aunt was right.